[Music]
in society is changing news I hope that
the society is changing news it always
needs to change you don't want it to
stay the same
why want to change for good like what
parts of it like the 90s I wish it was
the 90s but the 90s were a traumatic
time for me so let's move on
submitted by a [ __ ] stick a new chicken
you know I 5 H's an opinion piece argues
that heterosexuality is the foundation
to men's societal dominance over women I
believe it goddamnit
that was so deep horrible an opinion
piece argues that heterosexuality is the
foundation to men's societal dominance
over women takes over chicks it's over
chicks but fix into chicks fix above
chicks okay go on
under chicks all right so this writer
here she wrote a think piece for NBC
News she must be a feminist
she titled it I [ __ ] hate that word
she tattled it Miley Cyrus is split with
Liam Hemsworth isn't just celebrity
gossip it's a blow to the patriarchy oh
[ __ ] the patriarchy
it's household yeah that's I know but
like who so who are these people that
are like if I want to put point the
camera at the person that is hurt of
Miley Cyrus and Liam Hemsworth the
patriarchy pointed at the middle-aged
white males I think middle aged white
muslin UFO Miley's are they know they
got women like Cyrus are speaking out
about sexuality in ways that put the
power and responsibility back into their
own hand
yes she's claiming that so she says
quote men meathead heterosexuality to
maintain their societal dominance over
women women on the other hand are
increasingly realizing not only that
they don't need heterosexuality but that
it also is often the bedrock of their
global oppression so they're thinking
that being gay is a preference not it
not you're not born with it maybe she's
born with it because like maybe it's
lesbian
it sounds like that is your boring game
so they're realizing that they can come
out openly now be like I don't need no
man I don't think it's actually about
like sexual orientation rather than the
idea that heterosexuality being like the
foundation of how we see women is the
reason why I like men usually always
consistent talking about like
traditional roles gender roles ignore
like gen gender roles exactly that's not
sounds like I didn't think gen gender
roles really exist for like a long time
now really there may exist I think it I
think gender roles changed within the
decade like dramatically here maybe I
think yeah I think that well maybe
socially but like biologically like
women are more drawn to being more
nurturing like there's like some
biological aspects that still the
majority like kind of feel even if
outwardly in society they're like no I
don't have to do that but then like
inwardly like all of us have plants now
in our 30s because we're taking care of
something that's not a baby oh you're
talking about the innate need right so
I'm what I'm what I'm saying is that
within the past decade I feel like the
traditional gender roles have been
diverted so far off course where people
don't realize how far it's gone compared
to our parents and to our grandparents
but they still think that there's these
expectations that are old remanence --is
of the of the past so and and I just say
this based off of anecdotal observation
I don't know if this is like the
majority yeah but I think in the middle
is so much the majority but even in a
traditional relationship right like
where you have a heterosexual man wife
kid whatever I still think that is very
far from what our parents and
grandparents experienced all right so
this writer here she's bringing up Miley
Cyrus split with Liam Hemsworth because
when ends up what ended up just
happening right after Liam is that she
started dating Brody Jenner's ex-wife
and so they they ended up
some photos some paparazzi photos Miley
Cyrus's Liam and then these other photos
of Miley and that other girl and Kaitlyn
and Italy started surfacing it's like
they're making out and they've just been
spending a lot of time together
and so Miley ended up saying at one
point that she doesn't associate men and
protection and necessarily and that's
the reason why it's given her some more
openness to her sexuality and then
Julian she ended up posting this on
Twitter with a women's health cover so
she ends up talking about her marriage
and how she said that she was able to
decide she that okay so she's more open
in her sexuality as well but she's made
the decision to stay married to her
husband and because of that transparency
they've had a better relationship and so
what the writer here is pointing out is
that now women are she says quote
absconded from responsibility is the
quintessential strategy of the
patriarchy it's how men stay in control
and never lose power
so now women are taking back that power
by making the decision that just because
we've been naturally like conditioned to
in order to be a woman and to fulfill as
a fulfill your role as a real woman we
have to be in a heterosexual
relationship and we have to create
babies and like that's our main purpose
but now she's saying that that's that's
not like now women are realizing that
that's not all they live for that's so
crazy cuz I'm all the gay people that I
know they they tell me it's not a choice
right the minute that they were born
starting when they knew there are guys
or girls they just are already attracted
to the same sex so for this lady to have
an opinion piece about now they're
choosing to be homosexual it's like
that's what I'm saying it sounds almost
anti LGBT the writer to me sounds like a
mess Andres like a man hater and it just
really sounds like she's kind of being
like yeah guys you see if Miley and
Julian
they're not giving in to the patriarchy
now we got a win for us like it just
sounds like she's complaining and she's
just trying to figure out how to like
bring it back to her own narrative so to
me reading this it just made me think
like girl you got some man-hating issues
I don't know like you could be with the
girl too ladies let's get together yeah
that's what if you don't have to be with
that husband of yours the writer has a
point though because if I was mildly I
would much rather have the new
girlfriend than Liam Hemsworth the new
girls way harder Liam's pretty
attractive with you Nikki hey though the
girls pretty hot too so if I was mildly
I'd go with the girl and you have to
suck dick anymore I mean Miley could
have still been with Liam and just run
the house you know and she could just
still be the leader of their household I
like doing gate things with a girl that
would be heterosexual and matriarchal
did a level-headed man I don't like this
generation of just like I mean I hate
all groups because just because like all
guys are wrong because all women are
wrong because and then you're labeled it
was like so many different ways to like
you're Asian and you're this and your
agent American straight male who is up
yeah yeah voted for Obama yeah I'd like
to say that yes yes yes [ __ ] that [ __ ]
so Julian she was saying that she had
suppressed a lot of what she had felt
like the natural thing you're saying
yeah she had always suppressed it well
she's just closeted gay and then the way
the reai the writers bringing it out is
saying like well it's because of the
patriarchy that's why she suppressed it
right so that's the thinking piece part
but then Julianne saying but now that
I've delayed all the survival tech tips
I build up in my life now I'm able to
have I'm like she says that she's
connecting to the woman inside that
doesn't need anything versus the little
girl that looked to her husband to
protect her so with the part that I'm
confused on is it that it seems like
they're tying to issue like the
protection issue with the sexual
preference issue and I don't the sexual
orientation yeah the sexual orientation
issue and I don't think that it's
connected that way because protection
issue I think that's its own issue if
you need to feel protected or not
and then your sexual orientation because
it make it seem like Miley Cyrus was
with Liam Hemsworth and then she was
like now that I'm exploring my
bisexuality and more with another female
I don't feel I need protect it anymore
and that's what its leading to and then
now the opinions that you know the
patriarchal like mentality is what's
[ __ ] it all but you know to me and so
yeah I think they are a little bit
different yeah they're like being tied
together whereas like the women that I
know that are confident that never feel
like they needed protection from a man
it's a more individual thing and it's
not even a sexual it's not even a sexual
or biological because I also know on the
flip side there are dudes that just
couldn't wait to get married for that
stability so in the same in the same
lens of protection or stability or to
have a quote unquote rock in their
relationship there's there's more
dependent individuals and independent
individuals across the board regardless
of gender or sexual orientation or any
just some people that are more dependent
they're more independent and I feel like
people get into marriage and
relationships for more of a primal and
survival method than anything and when
you have money you have the freedom to
be a player you have a freedom to be
bisexual you have all kinds of freedoms
because you're not thinking about a
partnership that you're building with
someone out of necessity as well because
that is a survival mechanism apart like
there is a romantic aspect of it in the
first world but if you think about the
concept of marriage right it's a it's a
contractor getting into someone with to
have a baby with if you look at it
basics human survival basic is led line
yeah yeah yeah because the but but the
idea of romance and love and then
building a life and having a life
partner things like that that is a
little bit of a privileged concept when
you live in the middle class society or
above it's not the same for people that
are in survival mode so in that aspect
it's like yeah there there might be a
patriarchal society or something where
if you think about the traditional
relationship where the man goes to work
and the woman stays at home and raises
children that's the contract that you're
building because you want to build a
family you want to have kids and you
have these
primate primal desires to do so well I
think though that school of thought
though is still pretty prevalent maybe
not in California and in Los Angeles
specifically because now we're more
independent and and and like the the 30s
are the new 20s now right so women are
like well wait this is my body I don't
want like I'm gonna do whatever I want
with it right but like my mom's
generation is very much like that where
it's like you have to like I need
protection from a man like my mom's
thing with with her girls was always
like I'm gonna worry about you until I
know you're married so just you see
Miley Cyrus breaking up with them hence
rather than going oh ya know because of
the protection from a man because that's
just an old photo you're [ __ ] up yes
back to him yes that's she doesn't think
this [ __ ] is so rich she could have ten
bodyguards you should go back so if you
should smile
I guess patriarchal traditionally it
makes sense right so so she can argue
both sides of that coin of being like
dude I [ __ ] hated it I didn't get I
didn't get to live my dreams but that's
just what I was taught this is what
makes sense it's been happening for
generations but it works in these other
ways so she can argue both sides of it
but for her because she grew up in it
and it was so prevalent in her in her
lifetime that when I moved out by myself
she stressed the [ __ ] out actually you
don't have a man yeah she's like wait a
minute like what are you like I'm gonna
worry about you but I'm like I'm stable
I have I have everything I need I have
my own money like I'm very independent
she's like but still you know I'm like
well what if I'm gay what are you gonna
do that she's like I would still worry
because you don't have the protection of
a man so I think it's I think that
school of thought is still very
prevalent outside of of us is it like in
a very like literal way like um somebody
breaks into your house in all ways yeah
so it's literal and it's also by natural
yeah like even in a confident like well
financial like I was watching this what
they explained documenting on Netflix
right and they're talking about why men
usually make more money than women and
and that perspective came down to birth
it came back down to women bearing
children cuz like let's say Aleve let's
say both of us yeah both of us
gender gap I mean the wage gap wage gap
but that is that is totally kind of
reflective of what keeps men in power
sometimes like he was saying like you
know or financially being taken care of
because if don't can the girls make more
money than Cowboys but then their money
stops so if we're looking at both cam
girl and guy right if she gets pregnant
she could still probably can but she's
gonna have to take at least three weeks
off but she's already making like
tenfold of what the guy means you can
take paying us I think in that
particular industry but across the board
when a women hits the in their 30s right
they go oh [ __ ] I have a [ __ ] time
bomb like I I got a popular they have to
choose between do I want to have a
family and children or do I want to be
this [ __ ] CEO because I can't be
boring guys never have that yeah guys
don't have it and they can still be CEOs
right so that's why they're saying like
the the the if you look at statistically
why there is a gender pay gap that's one
of the biggest reasons why because you
know they're like why aren't there more
female CEOs well that's because a lot of
women want families and they want babies
and they want things like that so that's
one point out of many points which i
think is related to the idea of like
what protection by having a male figure
but that's why i sitt i feel like it's
an all power to women doing whatever the
[ __ ] they want especially in this
country you know what I'm saying but
like heterosexuality where like a guy is
able to provide that for a woman who may
want a family yeah doesn't necessarily
mean that like as a patriarchal society
guys are always just trying to stay in
power over because we all know that our
met we all know that our moms luck and
run the house for sure yeah
they run everything they run the money
they [ __ ] teach the kids everything I
just remember dad just [ __ ] sitting
there and watching TV and singing all
day and in working or whatever but like
really the moms are control of
everything or or in that timeframe wise
wise the the dad so to speak only the
one working and making sure the bread is
being you know brought is because he's
doing it for the family not because he's
like in this household I'm in power you
know what I mean it's like a dad that's
not the least amount of power cuz it
almost feels like the woman forced him
ago this is the only thing you could do
right now
go make some money gotta go make the
money you know I mean but but again it's
it's a perspective like I think Miley
Cyrus can do that because she's like
powerful in britches [ __ ] right but like
I don't know if that message said and
the opinion is right for somebody to
have that opinion I just don't think
it's like across-the-board
heterosexuality is the reason you know
what I mean I don't think you just
change it if you're because I like all
day long I want dick like I'm never
gonna want [ __ ] I'm sorry I just can't
it's too wet
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]